lo que vemos representado en este
diagrama es el ciclo económico que hemos
revisado en otros vídeos el eje
horizontal es el tiempo y el eje
vertical es el pib real lo que vemos en
esta línea azul es la producción con
pleno empleo en diferentes puntos en el
tiempo y vemos que está creciendo así
que esta economía está experimentando un
crecimiento económico tal vez la
población está creciendo y se está
volviendo más productiva probablemente
porque tienen mejor educación o mejor
tecnología pero sabemos que las
economías reales no tienen este
crecimiento económico tan bueno y parejo
sino que experimentan periodos de ciclo
alrededor de la producción con pleno
empleo hay veces que están sobre la
línea de tendencia como aquí tenemos una
brecha positiva este punto es una brecha
de producción positiva y también podemos
tener brechas recesivas también hemos
hablado en otros vídeos sobre política
fiscal las cuales son herramientas que
usan los gobiernos para cortar estas
brechas de producción por ejemplo cuando
hay una brecha de producción
y el gobierno teme que haya un
sobrecalentamiento de la economía
teme que haya inflación por lo que
probablemente tenga una política fiscal
contractiva y trate de hacer algo en ese
punto para cortar un poco la brecha más
probable cuando hay una brecha de
producción negativa y la gente está
desempleada el gobierno va a decir algo
como hoy haremos un paquete de estímulo
para tratar de cerrar esta brecha
bajemos los impuestos incrementamos el
gasto del gobierno este tipo de política
fiscal en la que el gobierno hace algo
especial en ciertas circunstancias con
el propósito de acortar las brechas de
producción es una política fiscal
discrecional es a discreción del
gobierno y lo hace con intención de
cambiar dirección de la curva de
crecimiento económico y en lo que nos
vamos a enfocar en este vídeo es en los
estabilizadores automáticos los cuales
son esas cosas con las cuales la gente
no tiene que actuar de una forma
especial para ayudar a suavizar el ciclo
económico o para cerrar las brechas de
producción como vimos con las políticas
discrecionales
estabilizadores automáticos
cuáles son algunos ejemplos de
estabilizadores automáticos uno muy
conocido son los impuestos pausa el
vídeo por un segundo y piensa sobre como
los impuestos ayudan a suavizar estas
fluctuaciones pensemos qué pasa en esta
parte del ciclo económico donde la
economía está en expansión
digamos que aquí o aquí que estará
pasando con los impuestos
bueno en estas realidades con la brecha
de producción positiva podemos imaginar
que los ingresos de la gente están
aumentando más y más las ganancias de
las empresas son cada vez mayores así
que nuestro cambio en los impuestos va a
ser positivo y no solo va a ser positivo
los impuestos no sólo van a aumentar en
términos de dólares absolutos sino que
probablemente van a aumentar a una tasa
más rápida que la economía porque pasa
esto cuando la economía se vuelve
positiva cuando se empieza a expandir
más cada vez más empresas van a ser
rentables si piensas en los impuestos
sobre la renta o en los impuestos
personales bajo cierto nivel de ingresos
en muchos países no tienes
pagar impuestos sobre la renta y por
cada incremento en las ganancias ya sea
de un dólar o por cada incremento de
10.000 dólares la tasa de impuestos
aumenta para esa porción de incremento
es por eso que la cantidad absoluta de
impuestos en dólares probablemente
aumentará a una tasa mayor que el
crecimiento actual de la economía
pensemos en el otro escenario pensemos
qué pasa con los impuestos cuando
estamos en una recesión así que digamos
que elegimos este punto bueno en este
caso las ganancias empresariales van a
ser menores de hecho algunas empresas no
van a ser rentables en algunos casos
incluso no van a pagar impuestos la
gente va a producir menos dinero cada
vez así que el cambio de impuestos aquí
es probable que sea negativo y una vez
más la tasa de disminución en los
impuestos probablemente sea más grande
que la tasa de disminución del pib real
el multiplicador de impuestos es
negativo y eso probablemente suavice la
curva un poco
ahora otros ejemplos de estabilizadores
automáticos serían cosas como pagos de
bienestar o seguros de desempleo
porque serían estabilizadores
automáticos bueno cuando los tiempos son
buenos cuando tenemos estas brechas de
producción positivas cada vez menos
gente necesita los pagos de bienestar o
pagos del seguro de desempleo y se puede
apreciar como una disminución en el
gasto del gobierno el gobierno no va a
tener que pagar esos beneficios así que
la disminución en el gasto del gobierno
es contractivo y eso ayudará a suavizar
un poco la curva y una vez más cuando
entramos en una recesión y empezamos a
tener estas brechas o excesivas o
brechas de producción negativas más
gente va a necesitar asistencia social
más gente va a necesitar los beneficios
de desempleo y eso va a incrementar el
gasto del gobierno lo que con el
multiplicador suavizará un poco la curva
entonces cuando el gobierno hace algo
explícito para suavizar la curva en un
punto determinado del tiempo en el que
se encuentra es una política fiscal
discrecional pero probablemente haya
cosas en el sistema como la política de
impuestos existente las leyes sobre
bienestar o los seguros de desempleo u
otros beneficios que probablemente
tengan un efecto amortiguador
independientemente del punto del ciclo
económico en el que nos encontremos
estas cosas suavizan estas oscilaciones
un poco y son conocidas como los
estabilizadores automáticos hasta el
próximo vídeo